hey 42 here the world is full of
different foods every culture region and
diva has their own distinct cuisine but
what makes some of the food taste good
and other food taste bad and why do
people like different foods let's start
from the beginning
when you chew food it is broken down
into small pieces these pieces are then
broken down into even smaller pieces by
enzymes contained in your saliva these
small particles of food then move over
your papillae which are small bumps
coating your entire tongue each papilla
contains between fifty and a hundred
taste cells folder together like the
petals of a young flower about to bloom
hence the name taste buds the average
human has about 10,000 taste buds on the
tongue taste buds contain chemical
receptors which have evolved over
millions of years to react to five basic
tastes these are bitter sweet sour salty
and UNAMI UNAMI is a word borrowed from
japanese that describes savory flavors
such as roast meat on source so that's
the basics out the way but what makes
people prefer sweet tasting food like
ice cream over say raw cabbage it all
has to do with evolution and the history
of the human race let's go back about
three million years at this point in
time humans hadn't yet developed the
basic tools required to hunt animals so
they fed on foraged berries nuts herbs
and insects we've all heard the term
survival of the fittest
but back then being fit meant having a
lot of energy so naturally humans
learned to seek out the foods with the
highest energy content out of all the
food groups fat and carbohydrates give
the most calories per gram this was even
more important about a million
years later when humans developed tools
and learned how to hunt because hunting
animals requires a large amount of
energy sweet foods are laden with
carbohydrates and three million years
ago
the sweetest foods available were fruits
and honey
but since fatty and sweet foods proved
to be very good for survival our taste
receptors evolved to provide a more
pleasurable experience when we eat such
foods because it's in our body's best
interest to signal to our brains when we
eat them which foods are beneficial and
which could do us harm
similarly our taste receptors evolved to
react negatively to sour and bitter
foods because in the Paleolithic era
certain berries and other foods which
had bitter and sour tastes were
poisonous to humans or contains unwanted
toxins so our bodies developed bad taste
as a defense mechanism against such
foods and it just so happens that the
types of tastes our taste receptors
evolved to react positively to such as
sweet and salty because there used to be
essential to our survival are now found
in many foods which are detrimental to
our health in large quantities in our
modern age where we are sedentary for
most of the day we no longer require
such a large amount of calories to go
out hunting so all those extra
carbohydrates which we don't burn off
which thanks to evolution our taste buds
just love instead clog up our arteries
on the other hand our taste receptors
react negatively to healthy foods like
vegetables because they taste bitter
which evolution has told us it must mean
they're poisonous because of this taste
aversion many people choose to avoid
such foods even though they know they're
good for them until fifty years
to go sweet and fatty foods were
relatively rare and costly so gorging on
them whenever we got the chance was
essential to survival it's only in
recent years where fast food has become
so readily available that what we have
to eat to survive is no longer a concern
as a result the number of obese people
in the u.s. tripled between 1960 and
2007 because our food choices are now
determined by what we fancy eating
instead of what we can forage hunt or
afford some evolutionary biologists
predict that in the future our taste
buds will evolve to prefer the taste of
foods thus are beneficial to our health
rather than those laden with fats and
sugar which means in a hundred thousand
years
McDonald's most popular burger might be
the MIT cabbage okay that's an awful lot
of rambling gone about what you should
and shouldn't be eating I'm sorry
here's a glazed doughnut to make up for
it but we all have different taste
preferences so why do some people think
this doughnut tastes amazing whilst
others would much rather eat this the
surface of everyone's tongue is vastly
different people who have a high density
of tastebuds on their tongues are called
super tasters these people experience
stronger flavors than normal and often
find flavors overwhelming super tasters
often order mild food instead of spicy
and drink their coffee with milk and
sugar instead of black to tone down the
flavors for their highly sensitive
palate on the other hand people with a
low tastes bore density on their tongues
are called sub tasters sub tasters find
flavors weaker and will often order very
spicy food and Heavenly season their
meals but taste but density isn't the
whole story as to why we all prefer
different foods
everyone's brain can recognize the five
basic tastes bitter sweet
salty sour and UNAMI however the group
of chemicals that can trigger those
taste signals varies from person to
person this arose from different
evolutionary threats in different parts
of the world most toxic plants taste
bitter
so in parts of the world with a higher
density of toxic plants human
inhabitants would have adapted to
dislike the taste of bitter food more
compared to people who live in a less
toxic plant infested habitat but there's
a lot of environmental factors that have
attributed to sorts of variance in taste
receptors in different geographical
regions for example people from malaria
infested regions tend to carry a gene
that makes them less sensitive to bitter
compounds and millions of years of
environmental factors such as these as
well as crossing gene pools has led to a
great variance in how people's taste
receptors perceive flavours which is why
some people find this too bitter whilst
others love it thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2